[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it is the Ramsey show where
we're helping people build wealth do
work that matters and create actual
amazing relationships I am your host
Jade warshaw I am joined to my right by
Ken Coleman is is there really anybody
next to you Ken I mean come on let's be
honest about that not right now I mean
I'm looking to my right I don't see
anybody to my right I do see you uh the
fabulous Jade War always good to be
together we were uh together with the
whole crew uh just this last Saturday in
in Chicago the windy city it's been
referred to and that was a great great
crowd and uh smart conference is what
he's referring to so much fun so and and
hung out with your husband Sam Sam was
hanging out it was great fun so super
good you guys came out let me tell you
Chicago y'all did that it was a great
weekend uh I came out smarter I hope you
guys did too uh but in the meantime give
us a call the number Isle 8825 5225 we
want to take calls about not just money
but we've got Ken Coleman on and he is
our career expert so if you are K set it
up inflation inflation's real let's get
to the pocketbook side of this thing and
as Dave has said for decades if you're
new to the program Dave Ramsey has said
for over three decades that your income
attached to your work is your greatest
wealth building tool and I focus on the
income side of things for Ramsey
Solutions so Jade I'll take care of the
outflow I'll talk as I can about the
income do I need a side hustle should I
be leveling up how do I get promoted do
I move and switch uh career moves when
I'm still in the baby steps the answer
is yes we tell you how to do it so
anything work related in a toxic
environment anything like that and Jay's
got great uh Insight on all that as well
too so that's what we're going to do
today Coolio let's go to the phone lines
we got Kristen in Philadelphia P what's
going
on Hi how are you guys doing good how
are you I'm well thanks for taking my
call you bet um so the reason I'm
calling is my husband and I are about
$140,000 in debt um the majority of it
is student loans um how much is the
student
loans so um together I have about 20,000
but he has about 90 or excuse me about
880,000 okay um so that's what the
majority of it is and then the rest is
just car loans um but we're struggling
with how to tackle it like it's
definitely overwhelming um tell me about
those car loans
40,000 so we have two cars the one we're
buying from a family member so that one
doesn't have any interest or anything
but um my car it's about 20 4,000 that
we still owe on it and then the one that
you're buying without interest how much
is that one um a little bit over 15,000
we still ow okay and then is that
everything because that doesn't quite
equal okay so that's everything yeah so
it's a it's about 100,000 in student
loans 25 for my car and then 15 for his
car so 140 total okay um so breakdown
okay you've got this debt you're
realizing hey this is a problem we need
to solve it let me know like tell me a
little bit more about your income where
are you hitting a brick
wall so um we both are like full-time
employed um I make around 63,000 um my
husband makes around
625 um so it's it's mainly just you know
the loans and and stuff it's going to be
like the next 10 plus years of us paying
it off and it's and it it takes up the
majority of our money we feel like you
know we're we're just paying like the
bare minimum on all of these loans that
we have and help me understand because
you're making 126,000 a year combined
you've got 140 in student loans living
in Philadelphia So High Cost of
Living yes okay I don't think it let me
rephrase that it's not going to take you
10 years to clean this up like you said
this is going to chire all right you're
both working full-time do you have kids
yet do we have I'm sorry what was that
do you have
kids not yet all right that's wonderful
because this is going to take you guys
working like you've never worked before
and I wonder if there's some places
within your budget that you can cut down
and live on instead of living on
120,000 maybe live on
90,000 right so we're getting on a
budget are you using a budget
yet we do have a budget we do our best
to try to live off of just my husband's
um and try to keep yeah but I mean a lot
of times we end up having to just take
my savings and use it for um like our
loans to pay off for car or for our rent
stuff so something something's not
adding up okay let's let me retrace what
you just said and I'm going to poke
holes in it so I suggested hey try to
live on 90 and you're like oh we can
live on my husband's income which is 62
and2 so I'm like either one of two
things is happening either you are able
to live on his
63,000 and you guys are being careless
with your spending or you're not able to
live on 63,000 because you're not B
doing a detailed budget and it's coming
back to bite you in the butt like you're
not being realistic on the fact like hey
we can't live on 60 we need a little bit
more so which one
sounds yeah I would say it's it's
probably more the second one but maybe a
little bit of a mix of it is that you
know we we try to live off of his his
money but also you know rent is pretty
expensive in this area um so there's
times where we've had to cut into any
savings that we have for any loans we to
pay or whatever that's a big what you're
talking about is a big swing if you're
saying we can kind of live off of his
but sometimes it cuts in with rent
that's a big swing of money because you
make 63,000 as well so here's what I
believe I think that your budget is not
a real budget I think it's kind of like
kind of a guide that you're looking at
here and there of what we should be
spending not spending I want you on an
every dollar zero based budget matter of
fact um we do these webinars every two
weeks here at Ramsey Solutions where
we're teaching people how to budget and
there's another webinar coming up on the
19th actually that was today there's
another one coming up on the 26th with
George camel one of our personel ities I
want you on that webinar it's totally
free 11:30 a.m. I want you to go to that
webinar cuz he's going to teach you and
breakdown exactly how to budget line by
line um and you're going to do with
every dollar which is free but that's
what you need cuz right now it sounds
like Kristen there's a lot of money
that's up in the air that's floating by
things like your rent mortgage that
should be a no-brainer like that's that
jumps that should never be well we had
to pull out of my savings to cover the
rent that we don't want that right Ken
yeah Kristen Krist I'm going to tell you
something this is about mindset U the
reason that you guys aren't making
progress is because you're being
reactive and what Jade has told you is
right you do need a budget that's a form
of being very proactive but you actually
need to experience some momentum so you
need to be looking at uh possibly
selling one of these cars and
downgrading in cars the reason is is
because you can knock out a big chunk of
debt very quickly and then all of a
sudden getting into that budget we find
something some money you guys have got
to work an extra job both of you you
guys have got to sell stuff both of you
and the reason is right now it's so
overwhelming you've got a narrative that
says it's going to take us 10 years
that's a mountain that feels like we'll
never climb so you know what we don't do
we don't actually climb it this is not
overwhelming so you guys have got to
make something happen and really quick
to see the momentum to high five and
then move forward this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
all right you guys are listening to the
ramsy show I'm Jade warshaw this is Ken
Coleman give us a call the number Isle
88255 225 uh the Ramsay show question of
the day is sponsored by neighborly your
hub for Home Services Take Your Home
Efficiency and style to the next level
with convenient solutions from shelf
Genie window Genie and class doctor
visit neighbor.com to schedule your
service professionals near you today's
question comes from Michael in Georgia
he asks how do you determine what to
budget for fund money each month while
in baby step two well if you're married
very very carefully and very evenly yes
uh you know because this is a tough
thing you know you guys are going
through it and this is meant to be by
the way a very small line item in the
budget when you're getting after it
maybe even remove it all together if
this scorched Earth I just wanted to
point that out J uh we when Dave says to
callers you know what you are not going
to see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're waiting tables you're rice and
beans beans and rice then the blow or
the fun category probably should not be
there but if it is there uh boy it needs
to be very very fair Equitable across
the board and reasonable and I would
recommend if you're married this is if
you're married that it involve something
that is really really lifting to your
wife sure or something you do together
just to kind of have a moment of we've
been busting it yeah let's celebrate
that would be my boy that sounded like a
politician but I was trying to get it at
it from every angle well yeah I like and
I like what you're saying and I'd
probably add to that if you're a like
the average person is out you know 18
and 20 between 18 to 24 months right
you're out of that you're out of that
baby St baby two step baby step two gosh
I can't talk today yeah it happens golly
but if you were going to be in there
longer like Sam and I we were in s and a
half years then you have to you have to
have those moments where you're coming
up to breathe and so I would say if
you're not average if you're going to be
in this for a long time Beyond 18 to 24
months then I would say if you're in
this like 3 years maybe and a four I
would add back that fun category keep it
low keep it just something that's cuz
you can't stay in scorched Earth forever
that's correct like if you stay in
scorched Earth forever it's going to
start messing with your mind you need to
uh schedule that out it's like a little
bit of a cheat to reward yourself for
eating healthy you know get a little
little little cheat snack just a little
just a little something something like
you can't go you're such a clean eater I
have to ask do you cheat A and B if you
do what is your cheat snack or cheat
food I cheat all the time number one I
feel like I do I was eating some cookies
last night I was eating cookies in my
recliner last night okay there it is
cookies in the recliner I feel better
about myself already James they were
grainfree they were like coconut sugar
like they
were hold on time out time out that's
not a cheat if the Cookie doesn't
resemble a cookie it's not a cookie it
did not resemble a cookie I'm talking do
you get like a Twinkie and just get
never that no never all right never I
can't not a cheat I'm talking like like
like a true cheat if I want to cheat I
would say I would make a B I would make
a brownies okay good not like freaking
healthy brownies just good oldfashioned
old sugar and awful things brownies real
cane sugar cane sugar all right yeah
okay now I can move ahead I can focus
now yes we should all have a cheat meal
from time to time all right with that we
got to go to Justin who's in Tampa
Florida what's going on
Justin hey guys how you doing doing good
how are you
doing well um so I'm bit in a bit of a
situation I'm a single guy 30 years old
I'm a firefighter here in the Tampa area
and my car I got into a car payment a
miserable mistake uh
$34,000 loan okay 16% interest with $773
a
month Yik yeah and so it's it's been
killing me um I'm living in a friend's
room in a house
good and the rent is 800 a month and
it's just I I'm unable to to get ahead
with my bills I feel like I I just paid
off some uh some debt I was I was in
this in these payday loan Cycles um
these apps that that I got so tell me
about the car tell me about the car real
quick because I want to attack this Jade
will help you with the rest of your
stuff but I'm just curious on this carve
what is the car it's a 2022 Subaru
Outback um what's I yeah it's it's worth
23,000 I still ow 32 oh so there's no
trading it in there's no selling it wait
a sec um well sure there is well wait a
second this is a you said it's a 2022
Outback or
2023 22 how are did you roll negative
equity into
it uh just $2,000
$2,000 man man yeah okay well here's
well here's the deal I I'll just give it
to Jade on this but I mean I if if I
were swimming in debt like you are and
the way you're feeling I would go ahead
and take the I'd go ahead and take the
bath on this thing um and I would
consider selling it and then we this the
only time we ever recommend a loan is
you go to a local credit union if you if
they'll give you a loan and you get a
loan for the difference and now your
payment's a whole lot less and you can
attack that you can put that in your
debt snowball that's something to think
about what's your credit like okay I'm
guessing it's bad because you've been
doing these payday
loans yeah so that's it's bad because
I've been laid a couple times on this
car because it's the price it is but my
credit I just checked today it's uh in
the upper fours it's like 480 490 so not
good okay so you're not going to get a
you're not going to be able to get a
loan um before I advise you further can
you tell me a little bit more about the
other debt that you have because I'm
assuming there's
more um so really there's not um like I
said these past couple weeks I just um I
was living paycheck to paycheck because
of the payday loans the cash advances
from Amscot did you clear those you paid
those off those are all done and never
and by the way we're never going to
amcot ever again ever right you've
realized these never again the they're
they're terrible terrible terrible okay
so this is the only debt is this car Noe
772 per month what's your
income income's about I get paid 18,800
every two weeks so okay 30 34 yeah okay
and that's for 40 hours a
week well our firefighter schedule is
different we work 24 hours on 48 hours
off so it's it averages out to 96 hours
a week can you get
overtime it's tough um it's not
guaranteed I have been working a lot of
um extra shifts for people PID cash um
and so I've been doing that think I'm
around almost 8,000 extra this year nice
sounds like he doesn't know where his
money's going yeah I think you don't if
you're making you're making $3600 a
month you're paying you know I think I
heard you say $800 or some for rent and
then you've got this car which is eating
up half of year like that alone he's
eating up half your check um I think
that you can work more I here's the
thing we can we can do what Ken said and
you can you know take a bath on this and
try to before you even start this
process get as much cash together as
possible because do you even have $
thousand doll
saved no I have
$280 in my account okay so thing one A1
before when we get off the call we're
focusing on getting $1,000 saved that's
the first thing you got to have that
because that's going to keep you out of
Amscot it's going to keep you feeling
like okay I have a cushion second thing
A2 is we're getting on a budget if you
haven't started using a budget today's
the day I would recommend every dollar
it's the best budget out there it's the
one that I use personally and that's
going to help you list out your expenses
and see how much money you have left
because other than if you say you have
no other debt you've got your car you're
living with someone um you you're are
you a single
guy yes I'm single I have phone uh
insurance and just real real quick to
example each check so I get paid, 18800
each check 11,100 or I'm sorry ,200 were
coming out each check and so and so now
that that's done I can can finally live
off of my paycheck instead of having to
re-borrow the money through those apps
yeah you've cleared up some margin there
yes my main my main question is I have a
friend who is a big blessing he offered
to buy me a $6,000
car and but I would have to voluntarily
get my car repossessed no no I'm saying
no to all that this is your issue and I
think you can dig yourself out of it you
can keep the car if you work like crazy
I'm talking about you're working like 60
80 hours a week not just 40 you're
picking up double shifts you're doing
whatever you can to get money coming in
and that money is going directly out to
pay that car note off because your
credit's not really great for you to get
a loan from the credit union that's what
I would do if I wor in your shoes this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you are listening to the ramsy show I am
Jade warshaw this is Ken Coleman and all
afternoon we're taking calls about your
life your money your career give us a
call the number is triple
8825 5225 and let's go directly to the
phone lines we've got Landon in Fort
Worth Texas what's going on
Landon hey uh so I've got some cash
available and I have
just a mortgage and student loans and
debt and I was wondering uh which I
should apply my cash to how much cash is
it it's about um a little over 100k H
how much over 100k just curious uh it's
like 105 nice where how'd you get that
money uh just savings and uh me and my
wife are bonuses and everything okay
cool is it just you and your wife or
you've got kids too uh we're expecting
one here in the next couple weeks very
very cool wow congrats so um do you have
any is this just so you've been saving
it up this is your only savings right
it's just this that's it uh no we also
have uh 60k and like singular stocks
okay and then uh 50k and a 401k and then
um we have 140k and a private Equity
Fund that's going to be tied up for
about five years okay cool very good you
guys have been very diligent with
savings um so how much is the student
loan debt it's about
65 and uh how much is on your
mortgage
385 cool now if I'm you I'm you know I
don't know how long you've been a
listener here at the Ramsey Show um but
we walk through a series of baby steps
and for us we believe and it's tested I
mean by millions of folks that this is
the best way to build wealth and that's
by getting back as much of your income
in your pocket by eliminating debt as
possible and thereby eliminating risk in
your life so if I were you I would take
the 105 and the 60k and I would start
using it towards my baby steps so baby
step one you've basically already
accomplished it's saving $1,000 quickly
and setting it aside and then baby step
two of you may know is you're going to
pay off all of your debt except your
mortgage so that's where your student
loan comes to to play so I would knock
that I'd be debt free from the student
loans today and then I would make sure
that I keep 3 to 6 months set aside
liquid um in your case I would do six
months because you seem like the type of
guy who likes to have plenty of extra
money set aside so I'd keep six months
set aside and then from there when it
comes to investing it looks like you've
already done a good job and you've been
del d diligent about saving but I want
to make sure you're doing 15% of your
income every month before taxes into
retirement what are you doing at this
point
uh yeah probably somewhere right there
around there so you're saying that I
should just apply all of it towards the
student loans even though the student
loans probably have a three to 5%
interest rate and my home has like I
want to say
7.2 and also we only put 10% down on the
home and so we're still paying PMI which
is only about 75 dollars a month but you
know if we put down the extra 10% it
gets rid of that PMI you still think you
should go you know try to pay off the
student debt yeah so let's tackle the
student loan debt so if I'm I'm talking
about that first I'm getting rid of the
student loan debt because it's debt and
anytime there's debt there's risk it's
not bankruptable it's going to it will
follow you to the grave and as much as
people say it doesn't matter you know
that there's $65,000 with your name on
it sitting right there and you've got
the cash
to pay it off today correct if I'm if
I'm hearing this yeah he's got 105 in
cash okay so Landon you have how much in
student loans 60 yeah 65 65 so the
minute that you pay that off then that's
gone that payment the the the monthly
payments which are coming due in October
correct yeah they're private loans so
we've been paying them okay so what have
you been paying what's your monthly
payment on the loans so far uh the
minimum payment 650 and we put about a
grand each mon towards so let's take the
grand that you've been putting towards
those loans that's gone that's gone by
the end of today so now the grand you've
been putting towards student loans can
go towards paying down your home you see
how we're just it's it's all attacking
the same thing but we're going to do it
in the steps that make the most sense
because you get the momentum and now you
have no debt except your home which is a
tremendous asset the loans are not an
asset the home is an asset so that's why
we have the baby steps in the order that
they are so now you're attacking that
home
and you're going to get through that PMI
you're going to get there a lot faster
now that the student loans are gone as
opposed to going after the home debt and
having the loans just hang around over
there make sense
now yeah that makes sense that's the
reason it's all about momentum how good
is it going to feel later tonight when
you slip into the bed and you have no
student loan
debt yeah I mean it'll feel good I just
uh I don't think so I don't think you
think it's going to feel as good as I do
here's the thing maybe you need better
sheets I don't
know something over 700 thread count
would make it feel good okay like talk
to us Landon what are you what are your
thoughts well I mean it's not uh I think
regardless um whether we apply the money
to the loans or the mortgage uh like
just in a traditional sense uh you know
I've always been taught also that you
know you want to go after your debt with
the highest interest rate and so that
why you know I kind of brought it into
question whether or not I agree with
y'all um you know me and my wife to talk
about it that's why I actually called is
wearing a little bit of disagreeance
about it well the difference in this
case the reason we're telling you the
student loan first is because again this
it it's not it's not an asset in any way
at least your home you know every
payment you P pay You're Building Equity
but with the student loan it it's almost
like comparing apples to oranges in the
way that you're comparing those two
debts it would be we could have a
slightly different argument if we were
talking about credit card debt and
student loan debt and all of that in
which case I would still say pay the
lowest balance first but it would be a
different set of arguments to support
that in this case you know again every
month when you're making your payment
towards your house you are building
Equity so there's something to be said
for that with the student loan it's just
hanging around and it's like okay I'm
going to put a little bit extra towards
it and I'm going to do a little bit
towards my house when you have that
focused intensity you're able to knock
things out quicker and I mean in this
case to in one day like today you can be
gone from your student loan debt you
know what I'm saying I I I think that
he's on board I think he's scared to
talk to his wife about it that's what I
think's going on which by the way is I
understand that I'm not like poking fun
at you but you got to cast some Vision
your wife on this based on what we said
we gave you the talking points and what
here's one thing here's a great argument
you and you can use our name on this we
tell people every day on the air pay off
your student loans and they do no one
has has ever called back Ken and said
hey I'm so pissed that I paid off my
student loans or I paid off my student
loans and I felt terrible after I paid
off my student loans and I wish I could
just go back into debt because I miss it
so much no one's ever done that Landon
yeah yeah yeah that's fair for sure come
on man I don't know you got this get
yourself a little mini whiteboard couple
of markers draw it out practice it a few
times with the wife and then say trust
me babe you know I trust me there K this
is just it's an interesting topic that
this brings up with Landon because I
don't know that it was his wife I think
that it's that cash money that you're
sitting on top of and it's like I have
this money I want to do something I
don't think he was I don't think he
expected that we would say basically use
all of it pay off your student loans and
then with whatever's left that liquid
money we talk about this a lot there's
there's a huge psychological hit when
you dive into a savings account with a
lot of money and take a big chunk out
out but you can't be focusing on what
you take out you have to focus on what
you're actually doing with that money as
opposed to oh my gosh I just pulled this
money out it's no I just got rid of a
massive amount of student loan debt and
I freed up $1,000 because that's what
they've been putting towards that yeah
it's to me it's about freeing up the
$1,000 a month plus being free from the
debt now and he'll still be able to have
he'll still have six months of big chunk
of money he'll still have 3 to six
months can pay the 65 off um because
again Landon if you're still listening
those single stocks I'd sell those I'd
sell those and make it liquid and I'd
set that aside that'd be my 3 to 6
months of expenses in your case probably
closer to 6 months and then you've got
you've still got 40,000 35,000 left from
your uh from that initial cash you had
throw that at the throw that at the
house and get rid of that PMI I mean
you've got so many options and it's
going to leave you in such a better
situation this is not a sacrifice in his
case this is a trade and he's trading up
for a more secure lifestyle if you ask
me and he did this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks Dr John deloney here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember paow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw and next to me do you still
say America's career coach can I you can
I'm just I'm just I'm just colleague K I
know you guys laugh at me for calling
you all colleagues well you're my friend
Ken I am your friend there's no question
about that co-workers friends com
comrades that feels a little russan
feels a little feels a little communist
I don't know I'm making I don't know
what's happening well we were talking
before the break about you know trades
cuz this whole thing is like you know
sacrific tradeoffs and Ken said
something that I found to be a bit
controvers oh boy here we go that I
would like to share with the American
people on the on the YouTubes and on the
podcast here it comes he says you know
we're talking about when you're spending
money you're out of baby step two and
you've got some extra margin and you
know you can upgrade to some areas in
your life I'm not talking about you know
going out you know overboard but you you
have the extra margin and he said says
Jade I would rather upgrade my sheets
mhm before I'd upgrade my shoes before
he'd upgrade his shoes and I'm a big
shoe guy so she's a little bit thrown
off by this now when you say upgrade
your sheets what are we talking here
what are we talking about over 700
thread count that's the threshold for me
see and I don't even know what that
means it means pretty nice it's nice
feels good on the skin is it like a
silky smoth interesting smooth can I
tell you I have linen sheets yeah I love
them yeah sure they breathe warm bre but
the amount of time let me I'll explain
it quickly we'll move on the amount of
time we spend in the bed uh in the
Sheets if you will I want it to be comfy
I will scrimp on the shoes for a while
until I can save up now I've never had
to make this Choice thankfully that's
all I was saying I mean I love a nice
pair of shoes but I'm going to choose
the sheets over the shoes that's
interesting do you know there's a couple
of things that I will not like there's
you're telling me you're going to go for
a really comfortable pair of shoes or
nice pair of shoes that aren't
comfortable over some good sheets I walk
all day sleep on ratty sheets I walk all
day when you're tired you don't care
where your head hits you just want to go
to sleep oh no not me I need optimal
conditions and can't have a flat pillow
that just goes to the mattress like
these freaking Hotel pillows okay so the
pillow is more important than the sheets
in my opinion if we're really talking me
it's a combo I'd rather spend more money
on my pillow than I'd spend on my sheets
and I'd rather spend more on my shoes
because I'm walking all day I don't want
to come home with my dogs barking
choosing between a pillow and sheets
like choosing between bread and water
you got to have both to live I got to
have the pillow and the sheets W you
know we're doing a segment Ken next time
you and I host we're going to talk about
oh that's right that's coming up
Thursday you don't want to miss Thursday
show tell them why we're going to talk
about the things that we are worth
spending money on and not spending money
on and we're talking about generic
versus name brand I love this so we're
going to go through I'm very opinionated
on this yeah and I want you guys to
leave your comments I want you to drop
in the comments you can do it on today's
show tell us some of the things that
you're like I refuse Jade I refuse to
believe that you know generic toilet
paper is the same as my charman like
don't Jay don't try to tell me drop it
in the comments I want to know is it
coffee is it wine is it crackers like
what's the here's what I'm going to tell
you you don't want to miss Thursday show
cuz we're going to talk about the
difference between generic toilet paper
and high-end toilet paper and my
analysis on this is not to be missed I
don't want to know about your analysis
George or Ken on toilet paper James
loves my analysis on cheap versus
quality toilet paper you're not going to
want to miss it well we're going to be
talking about it all right that's
Thursday in the meantime let's go to
Robert he's in Chattanooga what's going
on
Robert hey Jaden Ken how are you guys
today doing good we're having too much
fun Robert how can we help you hey I'm
doing well um first of all I'd like to
start off saying I'm coming to you from
a very blessed position um but I am
curious what your plan of attack would
be um my question is in regards to when
personal and business funds kind of
collide um so I'll I'll use round
numbers here for you um my dad and I are
5050 uh percent business partners um
we've got I have a $500,000 mortgage
okay um we owe roughly we're on a cash
basis at our office so we have roughly
600,000 that will be due at the end of
the year in taxes of realized income I
guess is how that works okay um since
for on cash basis I can get that down to
as close to zero as possible and kind of
Kick the Can moving forward as we have
done for the past few years but that's
sitting out there as a potential tax
that we have to ow right okay um we have
roughly 1.2 in a money market right now
um high yield money market kind of thing
for the business and then we have about
correct and then we have H 500k in
basically checking account for the
business that operates as uh operating
cash just as cash flow cash is King in
our industry got it what what is the
industry by the
way uh we're in logistics okay um I'm
curious what your plan of attack would
be normally if my dad and I at the end
of the year um split a bonus or
something like that take a withdrawal
we'll do it evenly okay we've never done
anywhere close to this kind that would
knock out my mortgage but in a rough
year which it has been the way our our
Market's going right now mmhm it feels
like it's still volatile and if you have
those kind of funds available it could
knock out my entire mortgage right now
but if we did that then I wouldn't my
dad would need to take the same amount
and if we did that now our kitty that
we've saved for years and years and
years would be completely depleted and
we wouldn't have enough to pay taxes due
if everything hit the fan so you
answered your question you just answered
your question in more ways than one yeah
here's here's here's the bottom line it
when you own your own business is great
you own your own business because it
goes both ways the debt in the business
is really your debt the money in the
business is really your money but in
this case like you already said you said
you know in my in my uh place of
business cash is King like you need this
money to operate you know you could be
on the hook for this tax bill and it's
nice to have retained earnings and it's
nice to have operating cash your
business sounds very healthy and it
sounds like you guys have done things
right I think you're tempted because you
see oh this is like as much money as
we've ever had we could both take this I
wouldn't do that I would keep things
steady I mean what do you guys pay
yourself what do you pay yourself out of
the
business we both get about 250 a year
yeah at 250 a year if you don't have any
other debt which I'm assuming you don't
right you said you're very
blessed that's correct we've been debt
free ever since we started after about a
months then so yes okay so it's up to
you truly it's up to you how quickly you
want to pay off this mortgage
we see that when people are debt free
they're paying off their mortgage very
quickly s Years Around average with your
income you could do this a lot sooner if
you wanted to you don't have to be
intense about it but my guess is Robert
if you were very intentional about
putting a certain amount extra on your
mortgage you could knock this thing out
in like four years or less if you lived
on less so leave business yeah leave
business funds alone and knock it out
with with personal funds what you're say
cuz does your wife work well let me let
me rephrase that it it's not you and
your dad can pay you pay yourself
bonuses however you choose but to to put
the business at risk financially in a
down year with some uncertainty in the
economy on the horizon there's no need
to do so you don't need to you don't
need to and you can still you can you
guys can still um pay yourself a nice
bonus at the end of the year but it
doesn't have to be a $500,000 bonus put
the company at risk I would never even
consider that you're in good shape
you'll be fine with the company stable
as the company continues to grow there's
a reason to believe that it shouldn't
grow um then you can do that when you
get into a place of stability if you
told me that the company was booming and
that this was a bonus that you probably
pay out over the next year or so and it
would get you that point then I think
it's a no-brainer but that's not the
case here so hang in there I love your
intensity I love that what what do you
usually pay out in bonuses like what did
you guys do last
year uh we did 50 last year my uh we
just buy random things it might be an
asset for the office or it might be
something at the house kind of thing so
you know take take the growth from this
year and use that to calculate what you
think your bonus should be this year
still take a bon even if it's a 100 thou
for sure take the 50 but even if it goes
up and you're like hey you know what we
both are going to do 75 or we're both
going to do 100 based on how how our
business is grown that's fine but it
needs to be reasonable and I agree with
Ken I definitely would not put you know
the business at risk for this that's
very interesting can I love I love calls
like that and I love small business
owners I just that's a fun side of
things but you do have to be careful
because before you know it you'll kind
of get too it's like you get too
comfortable with that money it's right
there and you're like oh we could just
do a little something something he's not
hurting in his home he's not underwater
and so there's no reason to just gamble
cuz that's a gamble that's all it is
right yeah no I think with his income
with his wife's income if he bonuses
every year they're going to be paying
that mortgage off licky split before
they know it they're going to look up
and have a paid for home and that's what
I'm talking about that's what this is
all about all right that does it for
this hour of the ramsy show we'll be
back in a
[Music]
minute hey what's up guys it's Jade if
you love the show and want a deeper dive
on your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth we
help them do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm Jade
warshaw your host today joined by Ken
Coleman and the number is simple 8825
5225 we want you to give us a call so we
can talk to you we'll talk to you about
whatever's on your mind Ken's here he's
the career guy and so if there's any
ever a moment where you're like Jade am
I making enough money is it time to make
a switch how do I make a switch Ken
you're the guy right yeah and you know
you hear the word career a lot of people
go I can't I don't want to do that uh
let's focus on your work are you making
the income you want to make um I'm not
interested in giving you a bunch of you
know uh advice about your resume but
I'll tell you what I will do is help you
figure out what it is that makes you
come alive so you get out of the bed in
the morning fired up and ready to go and
and we find that by the way millionaires
everyday millionaires from the largest
millionaire set ever done by Ramy
Solutions 98% of them loved what they
did for work you were made for more than
a paycheck you know collecting 26 or 52
however many checks you get in a year is
not your destiny and uh so that's that's
my jam that's what I want to help you
with and by the way that'll help you
make more money or the right amount of
money so you can learn to live on less
than you make and be very fulfilled not
chasing all of the things that people
get into let me tell you what there you
go that's my that's my spin on what I
want to help you with that social media
post you made you were created more for
more than just picking up 26 checks I
said yes yeah I fired it off this
morning I was just thinking like so many
people going to work today that just
that's the only thing they're looking
forward to is the next check it
shouldn't be like that that's freaking
depressing that is depressing so anyway
I love that thank you though yeah we're
here to help you with with work issues
as well so love it so with that let's go
over to South Padre Island Texas sounds
like a nice place to be from it does
let's talk about DAV let's go on David
David what do you what what's going
on I I wanted to thank you both you guys
I'm oddly nervous I preach in front of
400 people a week and I I'm nervous
around you too no well it's really the
Jade Factor she's so cool and she does
that to people just think that you're
just talking to me and that'll just calm
you right down cuz I'm not impressive so
that should help speaking to that Jane I
I agree with shoes over sheets and
cauliflower and tofu cookies are not
cookies that's right okay so each of us
get a point today thanks to David okay
very good all right
d my brother and I uh inherited a farm
from my folks uh awesome uh gesture from
them it's worth about 1.2 million my uh
we weren't going to sell it for a couple
years uh it produces about 355 in uh
crop Revenue every year and we're
trening that um so my brother came to me
two months ago and said yeah my wife and
I want to sell so um I I am a bational
pastor I work and I'm a general manager
at a condo complex we make about 155 a
year between my life and iine okay um
doing Dave Ramsey stuff before we knew
Dave Ramsey I got five Dave Ramsey cars
and a Dave Ramsey boat um I love that
and uh and and both of my kids uh
graduated college this year here de free
wow very nice very cool that was our
goal um to get them out and so my
question is we don't have a primary home
uh we have a 10-year contract with our
church and uh we live in the church mans
okay uh so I was considering buying my
brother out of the farm it would be a uh
about a
500 well we're getting a family discount
so about a $580,000 loan 20-year loan at
7% um so 355 of that would go directly
into the loan which is our guaranteed
cash rent leaves me like I don't know
175 uh a year to pay on on the
$552,000 loan the loan payment for for
the the year would be about 528 so we
could you know it be $1,500 a month for
us um and we would commit probably to
doing uh
three times that a month and putting
3,000 in towards the principal so would
it would it be something that Dave would
recommend is there a home is there a
home on the on the
farm my parents took the five acres uh
when my father died in 91 my mom died
this last year and they took the five
acres and and with the house in the barn
and sold that and they that was started
their you know their income so the
answer is no there's no home that you
and your wife could live on if you buy
the farm no no home and but I have a 10
year the only way that I would be out of
this contract here and my other job if I
died or uh if I cheated on my wife or I
did something that would be out the
church how many more years do you have
on the 10-year uh the the church
home uh I just signed uh the new um the
new
contract so have 10 full years that were
assured of this job and then I ass
signed a 10y year
contract on my other job why do you want
the
farm uh that's a great question it's
it's um it's not sentimental uh but we
you know we know they're not making any
more land and it's it's it's incom
producing at the time it's the debt that
makes me nervous yeah so let me let me
let me let me hit you then so now that
you answered that way okay it's not
sentimental it's only throwing off
$35,000 a year that's not lifechanging
for you but if you sell this it's
lifechanging true or
false well no hold on hold on true true
or false I'm not backing you into a
corner I just want you to answer it if
you and your brother sell it what do you
walk away with and does that change your
life yes or
no I I I don't need anything so I don't
I think no how much money would you make
how much money would you make on the
sell of the
farm uh 6
five I'm here to tell you that'll change
your life that'll change your life well
the the the question you have to ask
yourself is do I want to make
$625,000 or do I want to go to into debt
$580,000 to make 35 a year it doesn't
make any
sense but would you be telling me the
same thing if we lived on the
fun I don't know but that's you're
you're playing hypotheticals uh I was
leaning that direction here's the deal
my friend David I'm talked to you like I
talked to my dad cuz my dad was a
bivocational pastor you already have you
have a bad feeling in your stomach about
this debt and there it makes no sense if
it had a home on it and it became your
primary home and that's where you wanted
to live the rest of your life yeah my
answer would be different but you didn't
back me into a corner you're playing
hypotheticals yeah I I wouldn't do it
Jade do you have a different answer I
wouldn't do it I mean maybe I I have a
feeling that your thought is maybe at
some point you would build on this land
but that's even more money still I mean
that's just no we would keep the land
forever and and I don't know you know we
would uh that' be a legacy land for for
our kids but I understand we so I guess
my question would be uh so let's say I
take the 65 hey I'm up against a break I
don't think I can keep letting you go on
this one but what I what I would tell
you I already told you what to do yeah
David take the money take the money why
are you going to go into half a million
no almost $600,000 worth of debt and
you're going to you're going to you're
going to get 35 back a year he gave us
the key word he said it wasn't
sentimental and that's what I was
listening for not he felt horrible about
the idea of debt you're right David we
agree with you you're right David don't
do it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across the all 50 states so see
if chm could be right for your family
check out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
what's up everyone you're listening to
the Ramsay show I am your host Jade
warshaw I got Ken Coleman to my right
we're talking about your life and your
money so give us a call the number is
5225 and I can tell you this when folks
come to us and come to me specifically
they're wanting to get out of debt
they're wanting to go fast Ken they're
like how can I do this as quick as
possible and I always tell them I'm like
you have to get your income up yes you
have to get your spending and your
expenses right we're cutting items in
the budget but at the end of the day you
also have to get your your your money
coming in get that as high as possible
because that's what's going to make your
debt snowball move that's how you pay
off debt fast and the answer to that
question is side hustling and so then
it's like Okay Jade I know I need a side
Hustle but what's truly the best one cuz
we want to make a lot of money per hour
right we want to get a lot of bang for
our buck and um we checked the ramsy
baby steps Community to find out what
you guys are doing to side hustle and
really what are the best side hustles
and what you guys are saying so let's
see what they're talking about Ken I
love some of these so uh Christy says I
own a travel agency which has been my
full-time job for 17 years uh but I have
several agents on my team who work in
their own time booking vacations and
cruises good side gig if you like travel
so you can get paid to do something you
really enjoy and you get a lot of perks
so that's a really fun one um how about
Paula side gig she has uh with a direct
sales company she does it from her phone
anytime she
wants and it gives her an extra $200 to
$1,200 a month now that's some serious
progress yeah that ain't bad 1,200 a
month Kendra or I'm sorry Cassandra says
she babysits in your home for couples in
order for them to have date nights on
the weekends now let me tell you that
babysitting gig yeah you can make a lot
it adds up you're I'm out of the game
now uh my daughter's starting to do it
but I haven't asked her what her rates
are what what what's a going rate for
babysitter you got the littles okay so
I've got when I had one child it was
generally about $15 an hour okay and
then when I had two children it went up
and it's about 20 sometimes a little
more 25 an hour I'm telling you one
person charged me 30 an hour like it
depends on what they do like if they're
just like hey I'm just here I'm I'm on
my phone but I'm just watching make sure
they don't hurt themselves I'd be
getting greedy if I was trying to get
out of debt right now you know what I'd
be doing I'd be like the old woman who
lived in shoe with all these kids I'd
have like 10 kids at my house for four
or five hours a night just running a
daycare at night for my home you be
racking up let me tell you at those
rates I'd be like come on it's pizza
night at the Coman there are there are
moms who will pay cuz I have one
babysitter she's amazing when I come
back the cabinets are organized the
silver wear is organized you know
everything is perfectly stacked on each
other I come back she's organized the C
the cupboards yeah I'm not
to she can charge more she can charge
more because she does that so
babysitting I'd be saying bring them
over we're going to feed them they'll be
exhausted when you pick them up I'm
going to run the little ragam muffins
but wait they got to go to your house
yeah cuz that's that's how I'm going to
max out they got go to the shoe I'm
going to have yeah see I'm going to have
everybody come to me hey it's date night
and we have 20 kids and I'm just sugar
them up then they crash we exercise them
can you realize how creepy that sounds
come on kids come over to my house it's
not just me Stacy Josie's there why you
got to make it all creepy it's Uncle Ken
it's date night we got it all right I
guess it's getting creepier well this
one's better let's let's talk about uh
Miranda she says I do Rover I've seen
that it's a pet sitting it's pet sitting
it's an app and people can go on there
if they need like if they want to get a
dog walker for their dog they can
schedule a dog walker a dog sitting all
through this app Rover I've seen it she
says I make a decent amount of money
doing only Doggy Daycare and home
boarding see I think it changed my mind
I'm going to kill the dog the the kid
idea I'm going to go to the dogs we're
going to have 12 dogs over at the house
be great I got a huge backyard just let
them go crazy I like that it's less
creepy or Sarah she says I love driving
the school bus I also make extra money
by washing the school buses and doing
trips as well now that sounds like a lot
of work Sarah you're over here washing
School Bus my arms are tired just
thinking about washing school buses look
you got to do what gives you Joy if she
enjo do done oh that's a lot of reaching
you can only get so much that that's a
big roof she takes pride in her bus look
I love this I what I love about these is
they're clearly an extension of what
these people already love to do and I
think those make the best side hustles
tell you one I heard about recently guy
is washing trash cans in a neighborhood
think about how nasty the trash cans get
and uh coming in power washing uh who
knows what kind of chemicals he's
putting in there making good money
washing trash can so what is what are
you all doing we want want to hear from
you what are you doing to make extra
money let us know in the comments or tag
Jade warshaw or Ken Coleman on your
preferred social media and if it's a
really good one we're going to give you
a shout out on the show yeah and and put
the put like actually put if you feel
confident and feel comfortable put what
you're actually earning cuz I want to
know are you making $20 an hour are you
making $12 an like this has got to be I
want to know the good good stuff yeah
all right let's go to the phone lines we
got Josiah in Oklahoma City OKC what's
going on
Josiah hey thank you so much for taking
my call no problem how can we
help so um my wife and I we uh read
total Total Money Makeover we started
our uh started the process about two
months ago uh we' listening to the show
and uh we had about we had about $39,000
in debt in personal loans and uh a
little bit of student loan and we just
uh over the last few years we've been
paying that down it was down to about 20
we had 22,000 left on it uh on just all
of our loans and realized you know once
we started this we got on a budget we
got our spending under control and first
of all we just want to say we're really
thankful for the program it's been just
amazing for our lives for our marriage
and we're really thankful um but it's so
we we got our spending under control we
um we realized you know what I'm I'm
driving around two nights of a truck to
be still $22,000 in debt so as of
yesterday we sold the truck we now our
debt freece and we have cash and we're
trying to decide so right now we have we
have some Investments uh for retirement
set aside we're 24 25 years old um and
we have about $113,000 in cash uh which
we need we need another car so we're
trying to decide how much car should we
get um should we have a $10,000
emergency fund a $3,000 car or since we
just replac the car we're about to get
we're in the military we're about to get
sent to California we're looking for
something with better mileage should we
just get a little bit more car and we
have a very stable job so we're not
really worried about uh having a huge
emergency fund at this point so I guess
we're trying to decide what baby step
are we on should we just get the
cheapest car we can have 10,000
emergency fund and start 15% saving or
or should we kind of get a better car
that'll work better for us in the long
run maybe more reliable and have a
little smaller emergency fund to start
with so that's a really good question
let me put myself in your shoes so
you've got this one car is this car two
or is this going to be your only car
this is car two car number two okay and
what's car number one what is
it uh it's a 2010 Toyota gra 4 it's it's
got like 150,000 miles on it it's been
it's been good there's no no issues with
it there's no issues it's it's in good
shape um yeah it's in good shape you
have
kids uh no kids no kids and so is this
going to just be a Knockaround car or is
this somebody's commuting like tell me a
little bit more it's going to be my it's
going to be my commuting car um I'm I I
I'm the only one who works so I I'm will
be in you know California what's your
favorite color car you got a favorite
color oh man I don't really care I just
want to get I want to get two and from
work with a good uh good gas mileage and
something that's not going to break down
on me before you give him that car can
when do you move to
California uh in about six months okay
are you are can you guys do the one car
thing until you move or are you like we
have to have a car now would do we do
need two cars what I'd probably do is
I'd get a Knockaround car now and then
in 6 months when you move do you guys
plan on like what's I'm here's what I'm
thinking through I'm trying to save you
money on the move so I'm like okay if
you're moving are you driving both of
these cars over what's the plan can you
sell one off before you
go yeah I mean the we're in the military
so it's the our move is going to be
covered uh we don't really have any big
expenses associated with the move you
don't want to buy the car in California
you want to buy in Oklahoma City yeah
that's a good point all right look my
friend I I got a silver 2007 Toyota
Camry Hybrid only
69.95 with 114,000 miles at go AO of
Oklahoma City that's just one quick
search my friend I get a nice little car
for you low gas mileage yeah uh I mean I
mean gets great mileage and pay cash I
probably wouldn't spend more than 10,000
I think 10 is good search between 10 and
12 that's what I did and I got found
stuff under that so there you go I love
it this is the way to do it Ken Coleman
on the ones and twos I'm the used car
guy you are it's my new title here on
the ramsy show you found some good stuff
over there but that's what I do this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything cost too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
apply
[Music]
what's going on everybody you're
listening to the ramsy show I'm your
host Jade warshaw and this is Ken
Coleman you can give us a call and talk
to us directly 8825 5225 and some of you
are new listeners you're joining us for
the first time whether it be on the
podcast maybe you're listening on
YouTube or even Twitter we broadcast on
Twitter these days or X is that right I
did not know that yeah that's right I
should pay attention to James emails
welcome wherever you're watching however
you're watching welcome we're thrilled
to have you here we're for you and if
you're a new listener we want you to
dive in because you're going to hear Ken
and I or whoever's hosting talk about
all sorts of things the baby steps or
gazelle intensity or beans and rice rice
and beans or baby step one what does all
of this stuff mean we don't want to
leave you guys in the Dust We want to
make sure you know what we're talking
about so go to Ramsey solutions.com and
go ahead and click that get started
button and we're going to help you find
the best Next Step we're going to plug
you in you're going to know what's going
on you're going to feel support and
Community that's what we're all about so
do that go to ramsy solutions.com and
click get started and that's how that's
going to roll and now we're going to go
to Jessica she's right here at home
Nashville Tennessee what's going on
Jessica Hi how are you you guys doing
good you're right up the street what's
going
on well I just started listening and
I've got a couple questions so um kind
of just trying to do maybe step two and
look at some of this debt and I I
thought I was doing really good and I
don't have a lot of debt um and so I've
got a a little bit of debt that's all
zero interest and the whole plan is to
pay that off as soon as you know the
interest would start AC crewing but
after listening I would love to try to
get rid of that I also have two
mortgages
um but I also have a Investment
Portfolio that's worth over a million
dollars so I'm trying to decide do I
pull money from that to pay off some of
this debt or even to pay off my mortgage
um or do I let that keep making money
for me and just try to do it with the
money that's coming in does that make
sense yeah definitely well let's kind of
break it down and see really what the
details are so can you tell
me aside from the mortgage is how much
debt you have and what it is what type
of debt it is yeah yeah sure so I have
um a I had a
$10,000 it's really I guess a credit
line I had to get a new water line for
my house and that was about 18,000
that's now at
6447 okay and it's zero interest um
until February so my plan is to pay that
off by February okay um but of course I
mean I could pay that sooner and then I
got kind of roped into a vacation club I
don't know if you're familiar with what
these are okay um so it basically is
you're kind of like paying Upfront for
vacations and so um basically I'm paying
about $2,000 a month for that and after
nine years that's over but I'm getting
yeah so it equals um you know
like
160 69,000 I think wait you're paying
$2,000 a month and you're locked in for
nine
years right for a vacation club but you
but you get vacation so you get like hey
wait you're not gonna convince me this
is a good idea you better be getting a
$50,000 vacation for 24,000 I mean I
almost don't want to know more about
this um is my question is is there any
way
out I don't know I guess I could think
about um trying I think if I said hey
I'll pay it off in full early then
they'll cut it like maybe in half yeah I
want you to find out more about that
because I do not want you locked into to
$2,000 a month for 9 years so let's look
into that see if there's a buyout weigh
it if you're not sure call us back on
that um what other debt do you
have um just my two mortgages so my one
mortgage is um on my primary house and
that's uh 1985 a month I have um
$236,000 left on that mortgage okay and
then um I bought a lake house with my
parents and so I paid half of that
mortgage lakeh house with your parents
explain that one are you on the deed do
you yes I'm on the deed and on the
mortgage um and so I pay half of all of
that and they are too or is it just in
your name yes no they are too
interesting that's uh how much is that
they also live with they live with me
primarily um so this was so we're like
connected for the rest of life it feels
like um so that mortgage is is um that
doesn't sound like a good feeling I I
feel like you you set it up that way now
you're regretful which you should be but
well right so that mortgage was $680
$680,000 mortgage we still have 664 left
and I pay about 19900 a month on that
and they pay the other
1,900 right yep okay um y'all are some
vacation in people I know that's right
y'all are living your best life a lot of
vacation a lot of time on the lake I
know right um okay and to throw in
another wrench I'm I'm thinking about
selling my primary house and having me
move fulltime to the lake and then
buying a home um so I can have some um
separation uh you do need separation
youp kick them to the lake house why do
you have to sell your current house yeah
I'd kick them to the lake house well
because my my current house is 3 acres
and I can't upkeep it on my own my dad
does all of that and I could actually
get 600,000 out of my my house in equity
if I was going to ask you if you sold it
what you'd get okay so now now we got
something to work with we know we got
600 coming from mortgage one we're going
to keep mortgage to around because
there's a lot of details into that so
far you've only explained about 8,000
$88,000 of debt even though one of them
is occurring monthly is there any more
debt or that's
it so just the water line which I'm
paying a thousand a month hope to pay
off in February and then this vacation
club which you know is 100 whatever and
I'm paying 2,000 a month and then what's
your income girlfriend um I met 185 a
year so I'm bringing in about 13 to
14,000 a month okay so we're paying
we're paying off the loan next check
there's no reason not to you've got that
kind of money water one yeah just pay it
off got it okay so we're paying that off
we're looking into the vacation club and
I want you to get out of it even if you
take a bit of a hit I want you out of it
I do not want you paying on that for 9
years you make too much money like if
you want you make too much money okay
now whatever vacations I want yeah yes
with the 1 million invested the only way
I might um I mean here's here's what we
we can look at okay if you said I'm
going to sell mortgage number one I'm G
to pull I'm going to take home 350 from
that
sale well I'll I'll I have about 600 in
an equity at least okay but you owe 236
no I'm saying I would I could sell it
for 900 yeah she's all out she's walking
away with 600 let's go okay so I I would
sell that and then what I would I'd get
out of the vacation thing with the lump
suum out of that uhhuh and I would take
that money the 600,000 what do you plan
on spending on your next your house for
you cuz I want you to pay cash I mean
I'm in Nashville I want a downsize but
it's still going to cost me between 600
and 7
okay so if it's costing you between six
and seven you've got the 600 from the
mortgage the 1 million invested is any
of it in non-retirement
funds yeah yeah yeah I have um about
one80 in 401ks and then um
1.75 in actual like stock mutual funds
and then an IRA that's
220,000 okay I 220 um so the stock and
mutual fund allows you to clean all this
mess up yeah all of yes exact
is that where how did you get how did
you come across that money was that just
saved money or no no no no no so my
husband passed away eight years ago and
that was the life insurance oh my gosh I
see so sorry about that I'm so yeah I'm
sorry thank you and I have a
guardianship account fund for my son at
109 109,000 that the plan is to use that
for college okay what I would do if I
were you is I would pay cash for the
next home I I you know between 6 to 700
$100,000 is fine if you pull $100,000
out from the stocks or somewhere sell
off those I would do that um and be
totally debt free then y I don't love
this mortgage with your parents what is
your parents financial situation like
real
briefly um I mean they're both retired
um and they are making money off of
Social Security and my dad has a pension
so I mean they have decent money coming
in I want you to talk to them about a
plan to pay this mortgage off because
that's my next big step because that's
going to be the thing that's going to
continuously be around your neck and
making you feel like G like you said I'm
tied to them for life which you know
they're your parents they're good people
but I don't like that you're in this
mortgage with them and I want you all
out of it and I want you working
together to do that since you're all on
the deed this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're buying a home in today's
market it takes more than hope and an
internet search you need a team that you
can trust through thick and thin that's
why I've recommended Churchill Mortgage
for 30 years the experts at Churchill
know their stuff and they'll take care
of you the ramsy way that's why
Churchill is the only ramsy trusted
mortgage company go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn more
Churchill mortgage.com
[Music]
all right you're listening to the ramsy
show I'm Jade this is Ken and we just
had an amazing weekend in Chicago
Illinois for our smart conference event
it was pretty awesome Ken you did a
keynote I did a keynote all the
personalities were there Dave it was a
great time had by all and uh I really
love our Live Events because we get to
meet you guys we get to sign autographs
it's just great to get a pulse on what's
going on and I'm really excited because
coming up we have another event money
and marriage and that is hosted by
Rachel Cruz John deloney and that's
going to be October 19th I'm super
excited about I'm going to be part of
that one Ken so yes uh I think George is
as well is that true all of our money
personalities I think George is there as
well yeah this is going to be good and I
this might be a spoiler alert I don't
know if I want to say it or not but
there might be a cameo by Sam warshaw
there I'm just letting you know there it
is I I believe that is what is called a
leak yeah I leak leaking information out
there it's a drip I'm I'm dripping
information I like that better that's
what the kids say don't the kids say
something about well drip that's when
you're talking about like your clothes
or your jewelry yeah yeah I'm trying to
come on Ken listen I'm trying if I can
get my boys to talk to me then I then I
learn these things I was going to say
I'm going to tell they say things like
check the drip check the drip is that
right did I use that properly yeah yeah
drip too hard that's what I'm talking
about you can't teach an old dog new
tricks Ken I like the drip I know I got
my golf I got my golf outfit on today I
got the golf pants the pullover I'm
drippy yes there did I say that right
yes come on come on dap it up Ken that's
see I don't even know what's happening
right now I thought I was going to be
made fun of when I said drippy and I was
willing to sacrifice for the greater
good there to give you all something to
laugh at out there so well when you come
to the money and marriage event make
sure you you come I get invited I'll be
home watching football and for those of
you are all who are interested make sure
to go to ramsy solutions.com events I
think there's still some tickets left
but you better go fast because those
tickets sell like hot potatoes you know
what I'm talking about Ken hot potatoes
hot tamali I think Hot Cakes is the
phrase hot potatoes I think selling like
hot cakes is the phrase you you you said
hot potatoes I think it's hot cakes I
think you might be right all uh they're
sell like pan start using old phrases
I'm the guy and nobody gets one over on
me when it comes to the old school
phrases these tickets are selling like
hot cakes there I'm going to start
saying hot potatoes yeah you heard it
here first all right Greg in Boston
Massachusetts what's going on Beantown
hey thanks for taking my call and I'm
pretty I'm feeling pretty drippy myself
Ken yeah thank you from one dripster to
another not a dripster you took it too
far too far too far too far the audience
oh thank you Greg thank you how can we
help Greg sure sure so um my my
situation is you know we've been an avid
listener for a long time you know read
The Total Money Makeover like from cover
to cover so um so the issue is that you
know um my wife and I we have a
one-year-old and we have a baby on the
way and she's doing February wow yeah
thank you and um we have the light at
the end of the tunnel we are at the
precipice of you know basically being
debt-free we um we have about $88,000
left oh wow our consumer day yeah it's
been a long time coming about two and a
half years really struggling and getting
it done um went from about 45,000 all
the way down to where we are now awesome
great job yeah yeah so um the question
is now um with you know our one-year-old
and we have a baby on the way um we have
the money right now to pay off the debt
but you know with the newborn on the way
and you know all these medical bills are
starting to stack up with the uh with
our high deductible health plan we want
to know if it's you know if we should
hold off until the uh the baby comes to
or we should pay off the debt and then
you know gradually you know pay off the
debt you know with like yeah do you have
the money for the deductible set aside
as
well yeah so we have a an HSA with money
that's that's stacked up but it's slowly
starting to uh you know trickle down
because you know we're we're reaching
the end of that to pay off the um the
deductible and the remainder and then we
have out of pocket maximum that we have
to pay and then with the baby coming in
February we're going to have to then
have to double dip again because right
um so then the uh the deductible res
will reset on the beginning of the year
so my question is do you have those
out-of pocket maximums in your HSA do
you have enough for Bo for both years uh
right now we have about, 1500 and that
will cover you know the remainder of
this year uhuh and then yeah the next
will will reset so we won't have
anything left in the HSA okay um I would
temporarily pause the baby steps because
you don't know what's going to happen
and I believe that you're going to have
a great baby everything is going to be
go you know go smoothly have a wonderful
delivery but you know being conservative
I would just make sure that I have this
money saved just in case it's going to
give you a lot of peace and here's the
thing if something happens and you end
up having like a bunch of money you know
you're going to have this big chunk of
money when this baby comes and you're
going to oh great we can pay off this
debt and we're going to have extra money
after that right right and that's not a
bad that's not a bad thing you know I
get it you're like oh we're so close
$8,000 I just want to have the balance
be zero look keep keep paying the
minimums on it and then just keep this
money aside and if something were to
happen and you have more than the
out-of- pocket max for both years and
you're like this is plenty of money I'm
not mad at you if you went ahead and
paid the 8,000 off but I definitely want
you to have both of those out-of- pocket
Macs yeah you're playing it safe and
that's smart Greg and you're not gonna
go backwards I can tell you're committed
to this this is a good move and in the
minute baby's okay and everything's good
knock it out at once absolutely by the
way I got to give Greg some love uh he
used the word precipice that's word of
the precipice precipice we're on the
precipice I like that that's the word of
the day go look it up word of the day
love it let's take another call let's go
to Teresa in San Diego what's going on
Teresa hi hi thank you so much for
answering my call no problem how can we
yes so I'm currently planning on moving
with my mom I'm married uh my husband
and I we are moving back with my mom
temporarily for us to save up some money
and to kind of finish up paying our debt
my I'm currently in St steps to Super
committed with my husband as well how
much
debt um student
loans uh 80,000 student loans and
consumer Deb is a total of 32 includ a
card that's used for my husband's
business okay and we're left only with
3,200 in credit cards we're killing the
credit cards first and we're almost done
with that by October of this year how
much do you guys earn
combined so my husband is self-employed
um he may and I selfemployed for the
county so combined it varies I make
60k that's my income my husband is in
between
50 or 80 it just really depends okay so
we make about 90 to 120 a year and how
long are you planning to stay with Mom
there you
go excuse me can you repeat that how
long are you planning to stay with your
mother less than six months okay less
than six months okay if it's less than
six months go for it let that be the end
date and what's the goal that you will
have accomplished by the time you move
out in six months
yes so the reason why we're moving with
my mom is because we want to open a
business it's called adult residential
facility is to help individuals with
disabilities and they live with you and
by doing that you'd receive an income um
so I'm going to continue work to work
and my husband as well but plus that my
mom will be moving with us but the thing
is that we are trying to purchase a home
but that will be uh not finishing paying
our
debt I don't want you to I don't want
you to buy a home until you've gotten
out of debt and until you've gotten on
your own two feet this business idea it
sounds like a fun idea but it can wait
until you are in a more um stable
Financial footing you've got a lot of
debt here um the credit card debt you're
going to knock out in no time you've got
this car here you said it's for work I
have a few more questions about that um
but the the key point that I want you to
take away from here is I don't want you
buying a home until you're out of debt
and then take it a step further I want
you to have 3 to 6 months of expenses
saved before you buy that home and then
take it another step further Teresa I'm
sorry to do this to you but you need to
pick a home that's not going to be any
more than 25% of your take-home pay so
you're going to be saving for a while
when you get this home I'm not trying to
crush dreams Ken but I want to make sure
that when you do this it's 100% a
blessing especially since she plans on
running a business out of that house
nothing is worse than when your house
poor and when you're trying to work just
to pay bills hey that's keeping the
dream alive making the dream possible
thank you Ken thank you for seeing the
up and up on that all right this is the
Ramsey show this is the end of this hour
we'll see you next
[Music]
time hey it's Ken if you love the show
and want to deeper dive live on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way go to ramsy solutions.com
today to sign up for our newsletter
again that's Ramy solutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing real
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
I am joined by Ken Coleman we're your
host for the day and we want you to give
us a call 8825 5225 is the number we'll
talk about whatever you want to talk
about as long as it has to do with your
life your money and your career um um we
came off of a really great weekend smart
conference weekend we've got a lot of
other great events coming up and just a
lot of great resources available to
people so we want to encourage you to
dive in man this is a community over
here at Ramsey Solutions we've got the
baby steps group on Facebook join some
of our social media Pages Instagram we
are talking to you guys in real life
it's not you know a bunch of other
people doing our accounts all the time
we're there for you and we want to
interact with you we want you to head to
the website and see things that are help
ful for you that will help you grow we
want you to engage in these webinars
there are so many opportunities for you
to learn and grow and truly get
connected to something and when it comes
to your money and really just making
that it's a very good point you know
what I mean and uh you need to be
connecting with uh the the ramsy
personalities all of us on our social is
we're out there encouraging you
equipping you so at Jade warshaw she's
doing some incredible stuff on Instagram
and all the other socials and don't
forget uh the shows the other shows that
we have in the Ramsey Network the Ken
Coleman show okay I didn't hear a lot of
work calls today I everybody asking
that's all good head over to the Kenan
show anywhere you listen to podcast or
on YouTube uh and also on sirusxm so
we're here we've got a lot going on
ramsy solutions.com is a wonderful
resource for you to find out where I can
learn more about the specific area of
need where I've got some challenges and
I'm looking for Solutions that's why we
call ourselves Ram Solutions so ramsy
solutions.com is the website and the
solutions run by the way I want to point
out while we and you and I are back
together again on Thursday so for you
appointment listening folks you don't
want to miss this uh Jade is working up
one of her specialty pieces of content
here where it hits you where it matters
most your grocery budget your grocery
bills and I just get to tag along and uh
sample and eat and uh opine if you will
opine oine that for for those of you
that are under the age of 40 opine means
give my opinion on generic versus brand
name we're going to do a little
budgeting segment this will be about
budgeting that's really what this isend
money spending so you don't want to miss
that I'm told it's going to be great fun
it is going to be great fun we are going
to have a jolly good time what are we
going to do uh you know I think I'm
still yeah it's food based we're going
to do generic versus store brand and
we're going to do some food items some
drink items and some like homegood items
and we'll test them out we'll test out
by way did they post James our last time
we did this on the YouTube channel they
were to search it is it up there oh it
was so long ago I don't remember so long
ago see there's that's a shame we we we
sampled ketchup name brand ketchup did
uh name brand cookies so you had the
cheap Oreos the fake the knockoff and
then the real Oreos and then some
ketchup and I went through that whole
scenario and it was great fun for me
yeah and we're going to choose uh we're
going to choose items that really do
have a big margin between the markup you
know what I'm saying so it won't just be
oh this is 20 cents different we're
going to try to pick the things that
have a big here for you yeah we're here
for you I'm willing to eat on the air in
order to help you folks this is the
sacrifice that a man of the people is
willing to make Jade yes but let's also
be clear if you're in baby step two
you're going with the Twist and Shout it
doesn't matter if Oreos taste better I
agree you're going with Twist and Shout
get you better yeah you have to but for
those of us who are just not maybe not
in baby step 2 and we're trying to do
better with our budget but should we
make the trade-off then you have a
little bit more of a choice so that's
how that works join us on Thursday we'll
be doing that let's go to the phone
lines can we got will in Los Angeles
what's going California Love I always
wanted to do that I'm sorry I should be
beatboxing but I don't know how sorry
will we can't help ourselves no how can
we help
you hi guys it's nice to talk with you
guys you what's up yep okay so my wife
and I we bought our first home back in
2019 uh when the pandemic came and the
interest rates bottomed out we we
refinanced to a really low rate of 1.75%
on a 15year fix mhm um we have we have
enough money now in our taxable
investment accounts to pay off the
mortgage sweet so my question is should
we pay it off and I'm I'm just hesitant
because you know we have a low interest
rate you know and some of our money and
that is invested in assets that are
making you know 3x or 4X that that
interest rate so the money that you'd be
pulling out it's non-retirement funds
correct correct yeah and how much are we
talking uh uh we have about 475k left on
the loan we have 600k in our retirement
account so it is a retirement account no
sorry sorry in our in our brokerage
account okay so there's 600k in the
brokerage account what's in your
retirement
funds uh we have
425 K okay and there's no other
debt there's no other
debt I'm not mad at that I'm not mad at
paying off the home because if you
really flipped it around you wouldn't
borrow money in order to invest it and
that's really what we're that's really
the Crux of this argument now the key
here is there's going to be taxes on
this
money when you go to sell your stocks
and whatnot and so you've got to be
prepared for that I'd say that's the big
portion of this um if you make this
Choice which if there's no other debt do
you have three to six months of expenses
saved yeah yeah we do yeah I'm not I'm
not I'm not mad at that how old are
you we're uh 34 I'd do it I'd be debt
free that's my that's my story I'm
sticking to it yeah I'm not I'm not
about to disagree with you yeah you look
like you had a funny look on your face
that's why no no I'm just sitting there
thinking about the the the mindset here
coming out of this and and so anytime we
give Financial advice I want you to be
thinking I think I agree with what
you're saying what I'm thinking there is
is do you get it will are you on board
with it and do you understand what's on
the other side of this I mean it was his
idea I know but I mean like it may but I
mean are you all in you just wanted a
nudge or were you back and forth I did
want a nudge if you asked me you know
back in 2019 I would have said okay yeah
let's pay this house off in seven to 10
years times come where we're able to and
the fact that you know the interest
rates have spiked and you know we we
paying a low rate and we're making a lot
in fixed income assets yeah uh makes me
makes me question it and then and then
the second thing is is also behavioral
um if we wanted to move into a bigger
house sometime down the road what's the
recommendation for going about that with
do we want to pay all cash for that or
is it okay to take out you know like a
smaller mortgage to kind of cover the
difference between whatever Equity we
have in this home versus a bigger home
yeah that's a really good question and
what's your income by the way because in
your case what's your income
our gross is 450 is
450 yeah yeah in your case for sure the
next house you buy I would buy in cash
there's no reason in the world
especially if you're paying this one off
you know when you go to sell the house
you're getting all that back plus you've
got plenty of time to save if you wanted
to upgrade that's definitely the move I
would make and like I said before the
question that you're asking yourself is
if you were debt-free you would not
borrow 475 to invest you would you would
prefer to be debt-free and so that's
really the equation that we're working
with and I just think it's exciting that
you have this option you've obviously
done a great job in Saving and now
you've got this money to show for it so
congratulations you're weird people this
is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with us you're
listening to the ramsy show I'm Jade
this is Ken Coleman and uh we're so
grateful for you guys you're the ones
that keep us going the whole reason we
have a show is cuz you guys listen right
so keep listening and not only that but
we'd love for you to share the show with
somebody else if this has changed your
life or maybe you just find it
entertaining go ahead and hit the like
button or subscribe to it either of
those things would help us so so much
like share subscribe it'll help kick us
up in the algorithm and help other
people see the show and get access to
this content so we would love it if you
guys would do that today wherever you
listen to the show or you know you can
text it to somebody you could even text
your favorite episode that would work
and we would be so grateful if you did
that uh in the meantime let's go to the
phone lines if you'd like to talk to us
you can call us at triple
8825 5225 but for now we're going to go
to Michael who is in the city where I
was born K where is this Spokane
Washington no kidding that's right
what's going on something new every day
hey guys how are you doing good how are
you I'm doing awesome first off I just
wanted to thank you guys so much for
what you do um you guys just listening
to you and stuff I I went through a
divorce about 10 12 years ago and I uh
had to like start all the way over on
the side of the mountains again I'm
actually you know a little smaller town
south of span but I ended up paying a
$300,000 loan off in in just under seven
years that's guys just you know listen
listening to you and just you know after
I started listening to what you're doing
I started just pounding the payment and
just taking every dime that I had and
putting big balloon payments you know 10
$20,000 payments towards the house and
it was amazing how fast it went off and
then I sold a car and said okay I got to
get this thing paid off so but the
question I have um now that I'm just
totally debt free I I bumped up my um I
have a retirement from our Union but um
which will pay me you know x amount of
dollarss a year for every year we have
in but I have you know we have 401k on
top of that which we just recently were
allowed to do you know the Roth here in
the last month or two and so I started
putting the money into the Roth instead
of the
401 and you know you can do what is it
22,000 and then the extra 8,000 catchup
yeah so I've been just putting 25% of my
income into that well that's going to be
I just started doing that in the last
month or two well that's going to max
out pretty quick now so um did I just
take that extra money and you know keep
putting it in the bank or keep putting
that like in the stock market um I'd
probably go to
a I'd probably go to a Roth IRA once you
Max maxed out your 401K I'd probably
switch over to a Roth IRA is it just
you uh just me and my wife and yeah and
you could do the same thing for your
wife she could max out a Roth IRA does
she have access to a
401k um no she doesn't not at this point
okay so yeah I think that that'd
probably be the next step and if you're
still like hey we've just got lots of
money and by the way um it depends on
your income you might have to do a backd
door Roth but you could work with a
smart Vestor Pro on that um but yeah
once you max out that 401k move over
since it's a Roth by the way for anybody
else listening otherwise we would say do
a Roth IRA first and then maybe go to
the 401K especially if there was no
match but since his is a Roth to begin
with we'll Max that out then we'll move
over to the Roth IRA and if you still
had money left over you could go over to
an HSA which is great especially um it's
part of a high deductible um insurance
plan so if you have access to that I do
that um do you have access to
that honestly I don't even know what
that is I'm kind of stupid with the
stock stuff oh no it's not that at all
not at all let me tell you hey if it
makes you feel any better Michael I have
no idea what she's talking about here
well let me tell you then because I let
me put the let me put the cookies on the
on the floor um I didn't know about hsas
until 2019 so we're right there even an
HSA whenever you have um an insurance
plan that has a very high deductible it
usually allows you to have access to a
savings account that's attached to it so
that you could save up to actually pay
the deductible um that's one of the
perks of it but in HSA is basically it's
a health savings account it's an account
that you can save money into but it's
great because it's tax advantaged in
three different ways you don't pay taxes
on the money going in it grows taxfree
and you're able to spend that money
taxfree on money on purchases that have
to do with your health so doctor's
appointments if you're buying you know
prescription medicine things like that
so that's what it is if you have a high
deductible Health Plan you might want to
inquire about that if you don't then the
next place I'd go is probably look into
a brokerage account and a brokerage
account is simply um it's just a kind of
a catchall account that you can invest
it doesn't have to be used for
retirement so there's no penalty if you
pull the money out for a certain
purchase uh whereas your retirement
obviously there would be a penalty if
you were to pull the money out before
retirement age does that make
sense it does it it totally does we just
just last month or sorry last week we
visited my sister and and in Montana and
we found a piece of property right next
door to them and my wife's like let's
buy the house and she's always want to
move over there and so we were kind of
thinking about doing that and I'm like
oh my God I don't know I you know I just
got you know it's comparable maybe a
little less than what we might be able
to get off our house so I mean it's uh
it's kind of scary especially since I
just got debt free but U of course yeah
I would say if you do that in addition
to the house that you have now I would
only do it if I were going to pay cash
for
it okay cuz in that case you're really
treating it as an income property or as
something extra now if it were going to
be your primary residence and you were
going to sell the house you have now and
then roll that into the next house and
you'd have a small mortgage there's
really nothing wrong with
that okay well that's kind of what I was
thinking is well I was going to call the
guy and I've been trying to call him
today actually to see if there's a way
that we could put it on a small you know
a shortterm loan and then once we get
the money from this house you know while
we're doing some work on that place over
there just move over there because I'm
60 years old and I was going to retire
within a year anyway well I wouldn't do
it that way I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't buy that house until you've
sold your current house I wouldn't carry
them both at
once I would sell your house and then I
would make the offer over there and I'd
move over there and whatever you guys
choose to do in the meantime but I don't
think that I would buy it on debt cuz
then you you'd have to con does that
make
sense you'd have to buy that house first
Reon because you you don't want to have
two debts well your current house is
paid off your current house is paid off
but I think that it creates when you do
it that way it creates this idea of like
well I don't have to do this right now
like this was the plan but we're doing
this work ends up taking longer I feel
like in order for you to do this the
right way and do it the way you said you
would do it I would not buy that house
until I would only buy that house once
you've sold your current house since
you're going you'd be going into debt
for it with a
mortgage okay okay how do you feel about
that yeah I just I you know what I
didn't want to do is just move things
twice you know there's nowhere to move
all the stuff from my shop and the
garages and stuff the house is
considerably smaller even though we
downsize there's no garage there it's
just more like a big log house and you
know it's got a carport doesn't have a
garage there's really no nowhere to put
anything until we get there I was hoping
to be able to you know buy the place
somehow maybe on a shortterm you know
loan and then like a balloon payment at
the end of a year I definitely wouldn't
do that no this would never do that this
is too much risk just because you
haven't come up with a plan for your
stuff exactly you're debt free you got
this take your time breathe I'm not even
sure you want to make this move to be
honest with you
well me too I that's that's a struggle I
have as well hey I picked up on that I
mean good job Ken listen July 1 look
happy wife happy life I get it all right
but I'd be having a conversation with
the MS I don't I don't think you want to
do this more than you'd like to have a
hole drilled in your head he doesn't
want to do it did you hear him yeah he
it's like I set him free was like that
was the burp emotionally that he needed
well when he described the house he was
like it's an old cabin and there's no
place for my I'm like I would be sitting
down with the wife going hey how can we
spend more quality time or we being you
with your sister without me buying this
place I don't want to live in I think
that's the conversation steak dinner
Candlelight maybe I'd offer some type of
negotiation opportunity here oh don't do
it Michael you're going to resent the
house and then eventually your wife yeah
good good pick up on that Ken that was
good this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
w
hey what's going on you're listening to
the ramsy show I am Jade warshaw your
co-host joined by Ken Coleman we're
talking about your life your money your
careers and we would love love love love
if you gave us a call we want to talk to
you directly aa825 5225 is the number
and so we're going to go to Hussein
who's in New Bedford Massachusetts
what's going on Hussein
hey how you guys doing doing good how
are you good doing well doing
well so what can we help you
with so I am currently a sophomore
College double majoring in accounting
and finance oh oh smart guy smart guy
alert I try I try
and so my junior year I plan on doing
semester abroad this program it's called
semester I'm not sure if you heard of it
I have yeah nice
yeah so currently what I'm doing is so
I'm doing like a regular job on the side
wrers this one guy like this Sabo Fleet
and then I'm also like doing Uber Eats
and I set up a rooll for Uber Eats which
I'm doing so I'm trying to do about like
$20 a day okay or so if I do that for
like a year I'm trying to get about like
$7,300 and then I also have a full-time
job in the Summer where I'm a boat
tender
okay so I do make eent money doing that
so I plan on making about having about
134,000 saved up okay by Spring of
2025 okay and then so the whole thing is
about $40,000 which is pretty siep so
and my family so like the EFC is like
zero so sorry the what is
zero the EFC for this
good what is that
EFC so I do like a um fincial estimator
online for their website and I was told
I was gonna be about
$7,000 oh okay got it but instead you're
not getting
any no so like I put my EFC at zero to
999 right so bottom line is if I let me
let me help speed us along here husin so
if I'm hearing you right you think
you're going to be able to make between
13 and $14,000 Max before uh the time
would come to pay for this which is a
$40,000 Bill am I understanding you
right um so yeah so I need so the total
bill is 30,000 but I need about 10,000
in cash okay so I'm just hoping so I
know I can get the tuition down to
20,000 with scholarships and financial
aid and then have 10,000 to spend so I
was asking you if you think it's worth
it take out a $20,000 no no no no no let
me let me ask a question before we go
further into that is this the only time
you can do this and I'm I'm totally
ignorant as to this situation because I
don't have kids in college yet is this
the only semester that this is offered
or could you do it in the
future so I mean I'm graduating in four
years or in two years right and I do
plan on getting my NBA but I just feel
like this is like a once in a lifetime
opportunity who saying and I want you to
have it I'm asking could we push this
further into the next two years you have
more so that you have more time to save
the
money we I mean I could do it my the end
of my like the last year but I feel like
like the last year college would be like
heavily trying to find internships and
like especially going grad school but
that is a possibility of course it is so
Jade why is it that we are so anti- him
taking a $20,000 loan out to study
overseas because it's debt there it is
and it's going to follow you and there's
going to be interest
and you're going to be on the hook for
this and here's what I can tell you from
my own personal experience in college
debt hits different like you think oh
it's $20,000 like when I get out I'll be
working and I'll be able to you know
bring that money in and it's not going
to feel it but then reality hits and
it's like oh I might not have gotten the
job I thought I was going to get and I
didn't get it when I thought I was going
to get it and oh man the cost of living
is so much more expensive than I thought
and all these things start hitting you
and you realize man that debt and that
payment is more than I thought it was
that's thing one thing two is everything
we do every decision we make we're
setting a precedent and we're telling
oursel this is how I live my life this
is what I do and so when you make the
decision I'm a person who takes out debt
that's what you're telling yourself I'm
a person who goes into debt to get the
things that I want Bo and that is a very
big Line in the Sand that you draw and
that's something that that's a line in
the say I don't want you to draw you
have the opportunity here right now to
decide I'm a person who does not take
out debt to get what I want I'm a person
who finds a way who works hard and pays
cash and this is such a good time to
decide that that's who you're going to
be like you're in college this is the
time to make that decision hus sayin
what if I told you what if I told you
that you could save up the cash and pay
for this amazing experience abroad and I
agree with you I mean this is a lifetime
experience bucket list thing yeah we
want you to be able to I want have what
if I told you you could save up the
money for it and still line up a job
Andor internship and not come out of
college with that degree um and and go
oh I don't have anywhere to go what if I
told you both things were possible what
would you say back to
me I mean I'd be pretty
amazed well I'm telling you that's true
so let's just play this out for a minute
okay so how much longer would it take
you let's be
realistic to come up with the additional
money
um I mean So currently I pay about like9
to $10,000 for like School this year and
I've been working in the summer like
every single
um wow sorry I've been working like all
four seasons just trying to pay for
school so I've been like working and I
don't have any student Lo on me I've
been paying good for you so let's just
play this out how many more months let's
just I'm not holding you to this I'm
just getting your brain going because
we're going to have to let you go in a
few minutes and I want you to have have
the mindset and then something tactical
to play off of how many more extra
months uh would it take you to save up
that additional money so that we pay
cash for the semester
abroad oh god um take a guess and
educate a guest you're a smart
guy probably an extra year great so now
now we got a goal because here's what I
want for you I want you to come away
from that semester abroad coming back
home going
that was amazing and I don't owe a penny
and now I'm on with the rest of my life
I feel like like the minute I come back
I'm like well that was fun but now I
have $30,000 to pay $20,000 exactly
that's my point and dude this is you
gutten it out hustling for 12 months and
I think here here hear me on this I
think what you told me earlier when you
were like hey my goal is to make 20
bucks a day I think you could do so much
better than that that like with Uber I
think this summer I think that you can
earn far more than what you think you
can earn I know that you're a full-time
student um but I think that you can find
some things that pay better for
part-time and I think you need to dig
into what you're already good at and
passionate about in order to make that
happen that's where I'm going Jus I'm
just wondering are you at a place where
you could do some freelance some
contract accounting
work oh I mean so you have an internship
lined up with um price waterhous Coopers
no I know but hold on forget that I'm
saying if I come to you with my little
small business I a Hussein I'm a
disaster yeah can you do some
bookkeeping for can you do some
bookkeeping for me what would you
say I would say I would say I could
probably honestly start doing that end
of this year because I'm first I'm
starting to take okay so here's my point
to Jade's Point that's the real money
there you can start making way more than
Uber Eats and you're yeah are you
working late and working early yes but
you could sleep when you die you're
young and that's going to give you
experience going into what you want to
do after school right all of this is
filtering into the experience you know
what I'm saying this makes sense we're
not just doing Uber Eats right getting
experience in the real world I'm telling
you you know me small business people
and by the way not just in New Bedford
you know this Hussein I'm like I'm a
dinosaur compared to you you could be
doing stuff online uh helping people
around the world with your abilities so
you got to you got to see who's saying
the way that we see you oh yeah and that
is a very intelligent young man who's
got a plan who's got some skill sets he
can make some cash come on he's paid his
way through college thus far a major
shout out H major shout out major job
way to go this is a smart kid who's
saying We are rooting for you we we see
something in you dude you're going to be
amazing and and you're going to do this
abroad program and you're going to do
you're going to pay cash for it make
sure you send Jade and I a postcard
Ramsey Solutions headquarters send us a
postcard Hussein yeah love that this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw this is Ken Coleman our
scripture and quote of the day but you
take courage do not let your hands be
weak for your work shall be rewarded
that's 2 Chronicles 15:7 and uh you know
our quote of the day can I think you
need to read this one because you have
the voice for it oh is that oh yeah
struggling with the voice these days and
so I'm down to octaves uh James has got
a sense of humor I'm never gonna quit
cuz quitting just ain't my stick I'm
never ever quit Barry White I wish I
could get in Barry's category I never
will but that's my best attempt thank
you
uh y'all be praying for The Voice you
know speaking of need some loes speaking
of never going to quit going to quit I
got to let you guys in on a a
conversation Ken and I were just having
before the break we were talking about
college oh and we were talking about I
like this you know he's talking about
his kids which kids he thinks will go to
college which kids he thinks won't I was
telling him one of my regrets is I feel
like I should have stopped College
because it did not and I knew it it was
not feeding into where I was going and I
knew that that it wasn't feeding into
where I was going cuz I was a musician
and what was your major commercial music
but you didn't need it you realized you
didn't need it I didn't need it and I
was learning more from my outside
experiences because the thing with and
and maybe it was my school I mean this
is not for everybody but the the thing
is schools can only be so in the now you
know what I mean like they can't buy
everything new every single year so
they're not always up to dat so there's
a lot of things that weren't quite up to
Snuff and when you actually get out
there and you're doing the work you
realize oh my gosh this is the operating
you know this is how everybody's making
music not like that here's what the jobs
are really you know you're you're on the
job so you're learning in real time and
that's just in certain Fields especially
in the Arts it's invaluable and so I was
saying you know I honestly probably
would have gone back in maybe my
sophomore year I probably would have
been like no that's good I'm done and I
want people to hear the rest of that
story so you would have then only had
how much debt oh gosh I probably would
have come out with maybe 10 10 or 15 and
you traveled the world with Sam you've
sung in how many countries oh over let's
see 100 200 200 193 and on major Cruise
Lines you name it you've opened you've
done it the reason I'm te I'm teeing you
up she would never tell you this but I
just I'm I'm pulling a fast one on my
friend pull a fast one because you at
our after our postmart conference dinner
MH you shared with me and Sam your Cubs
mhm a story about a music teacher oh I
see where you're going take me there and
then I'm I'm I'm going tie it up but I
want you to tell that story because it's
very important it is important so you
know I think we all come across moments
that we go that sucked that was hard and
in the moment you think like this is the
worst thing ever but you're glad it
happened cuz it pushes you forward I
don't remember did I tell you this story
you told me the story you set You piano
the old lady oh I don't remember telling
you this okay yeah um you come in there
you're all geeked up cuz you're nervous
it's a heart exam okay so we do these
things they called juries and you do it
after every semester and it's basically
a chance for you to show your
proficiency so my jury that that that
quarter was to show you can site read
you can play this piece you can play
that piece so I think it consisted of
four different areas where you show your
proficiency oh this is fun real quick
inter we have three ladies in the lobby
that are all music teachers or piano
teachers and they're all shaking their
head oh this is great you guys are my
backup singers on this this is great all
right so this is a great story everybody
guys this is really huge because a lot
of people need to hear this story today
I promise you so when you're site
reading the whole point is you're
getting a piece of music for the first
time and you're showing how well you can
read through it right and so that's what
happened I get the site the site reading
piece and I start playing through it and
I'm like I'm doing pretty good of course
you're going to stumble through it a
little bit right teachers yes they're
shaking their head yes you're going to
stumble through it a little bit but the
the gist is okay you're you've got the
gist of the piece and you can read you
can read so after I did that it was the
last piece of the of the test and I'm
thinking man I I just I nailed that I
did a good job instead so all the people
in the jury it's like the faculty heads
so my my piano teacher she says well
you're a waste of
time and if you're not serious about
this you should quit now and she's like
just railing on me and I'm thinking what
the heck like what is happening so I'm
like tears are coming down my eyes my
husband is like peeking through the
window to see how I'm doing and when he
hears this he's just like he sees that
I'm just like Shattered by this I found
out later that some of the other
students got the site reading piece
ahead of time and they were able to look
at it and see what it was so they were
more prepared and I'm like I literally
just sight readit so that's what
happened she told me that I should
probably choose a different major and
clearly I wasn't serious about music and
and I I was wasting their time and all
these things now here's why now so I'm
going to jump in cuz here's why I asked
her to tell that story I didn't plan any
of this uh but sometimes you just got to
go with your gut and there are a lot of
people out there that are listening
watching today that you're still holding
on to a voice like that that that that
that stepped all over your heart 15 20
25 30 years ago and I don't know what
was going wrong with that lady that day
no I'm not that old Kim no I know you're
not I'm just saying I'm just saying that
lady stepped all over you because she
had a complex or she had something going
wrong in her life that day we're not
telling the story to judge her well we
are telling the story to say that uh you
can put yourself in front of some people
sometime that are supposedly your
instructors your coaches your guide a
person of influence and they can crap
all over you and put a voice in your
head that takes you years decades
sometimes never get over it and all that
to say that's from a institution of
Higher Learning she could have dropped
dropped out and she should have dropped
out according to Jade because she went
on to become an absolute freaking
Superstar and she could still sing her
fanny off so I'm telling you she didn't
need that validation but you were
looking for it well look and I got to
tell you we're in a place in this world
now where we are still telling kids that
college is the only way to success and
that's the biggest bunch of hot stinking
garbage from hell oh get it's we got to
get to the point folks where we look at
it and we go wait a second is this about
is this about Prestige or is this about
preparation to do the thing that these
young people want to do with their life
and are we as parent so worried about
whatever he's going to say about us
based on where our kid goes to school
and I'm going to tell you what's coming
down the pike we are seeing a shortage
in the trades in manufacturing and very
soon you're going to see kids going
straight from high school into the
workforce and if Kobe Bryant and Kevin
Garnett could do it your kid can do it
and we've got to wake up America it's
not worth saddling these young people
with Decades of Despair because of
student loans that's what it is it is
this is big business big business and
we've been told by the federal
government and by private uh shyers that
are putting student loans on the backs
of young people that this is okay
because it's the ticket to guaranteed
success and the only thing that a
student loan is guaranteeing is
desperation despair depression
dysfunction you name it I'm sick of it
it's time we stood up as the people and
said to Washington DC hey you know what
why don't we shut this program down or
why don't we put some regulation in
place to tell the the the colleges and
universities that you got to stop
raising tuition from 2010 to
2022 we saw College tuition raise at a
12 1/2% clip wow where inflation Rose at
2 and 1/2% that is price gouging it's
manipulation and it's wrong and we got
to say enough is
enough that's a slow clap Ken James I'd
say sorry but I wouldn't mean
it I love it that was great listen it's
time it's time now listen if it's the
right way and the only way go for it but
for heaven's sakes pay cash and we're
here to help you for heaven's sakes pay
Ken I'm I know I I apologize but your
story fires me up cuz it makes me angry
it makes me angry you got go into
student loan debt to have some old
battle axe who somebody pissed in her
Corn Flakes that morning and she craps
all over your spirit look I will say
just wrong folks I don't take it back
because that F give me my money back
Tennessee state that hey okay we're call
we're naming names up in here I didn't
name her yeah but we named I remembered
her name I was listening I was paying
attention Ken you didn't think I was
paying attention no you're paying
attention allay look we're naming names
up in this place and Ken is right look
but here's all that to say pay cash for
college and at the end of the day look
the words that folks say guys you can
let it break you down or you can let it
build you and you did you can use that
as fuel so if you ever had anybody talk
to you like that just know let it be
your fuel man let it push you to keep
going that's what Sam and I did but um
thanks for listening today I'm proud of
you friend Ken I you got me fired up man
you went into like a Johnny Cochran mode
that was great you're listening to the
Ramsay show that does it for this hour
we'll see you next time
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the ramsy baby steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click the get started
button we'll help you figure out the
best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started